since moongeun became president the
South Korean government has cracked down
on North Korean defectors raising
awareness of the horrors they endured
under the Kim regime North Korea is
responsible for the death of millions by
starvation it has imprisoned tens of
thousands and political gulags and Kim
jong-un arguably runs the cruelest
tyranny in the world it's no wonder that
each year more than 1,000 North Koreans
risk their lives to escape but instead
of praising defectors for highlighting
these abuses the democratically elected
moon government has chosen to silence
them as part of its policy of reproach
Minh TWiT the North moons government has
repeatedly asked defectors to stop
criticizing North Korea as it did during
the 2018 Olympics but it doesn't stop
there
it has allegedly used security services
to spy on defectors denied their human
rights group to access to government
support proposed textbook edits that
minimize North Korea's military
provocations and prevented defectors
from sending information pamphlets about
South Korea across the border the goal
of bringing peace to the Korean
Peninsula is a noble one but
prioritizing unification over human
freedom is not the answer
do you think South Korea should do more
to support North Korean defectors let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like to see our
scholars cover in 60 seconds and be sure
to LIKE and subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI